ses finances sont opaques ses dépenses
et ses investissements
gardez dans le plus grand secret
impossible d'évaluer la fortune de
l'église catholique romaine
ces revenus là jim hebdomadaire d'un
milliard de fidèles dans le monde mais
surtout des immeubles terrains
investissements dans des entreprises à
travers la planète
l'église fondée sur le message
d'humilité de jésus est une puissance
politique une société milliardaire
l'église catholique est une énorme
entreprise commerciale éclaboussé par
des scandales sexuels depuis trois
décennies
elle n'a pas perdu son lustre comment
peut-être s'en sortir à si bon compte
qui paient pour les péchés de l'église
dans des écoles des orphelinats des
paroisses dp2 faits se sont cachés dans
les rangs des religieux
le québec a connu quelques procès
criminel et seulement deux recours
collectif contre la congrégation de
sainte-croix 1 contre les rédemptoristes
311 victimes ont été indemnisées pour
avoir été abusée sexuellement
lorsqu'elle était enfant
cela point de l'asbl vraiment oui moi je
suis prête à bouder que demain matin les
gens dévoilent tout il ya des locaux
collectifs compte à peu près toutes les
communautés religieuses qui ont été un
des comme d'autres enseignants tout
peut-être pas mais il y en a d'autres
dans le collimateur juridique
les frères de la miséricorde les clercs
de saint viateur les frères maristes
sont aussi visés par des recours
collectifs maître alain arsenault a
tenté un deuxième recours contre la
congrégation de sainte-croix des abus
qui aurait eu lieu dans plusieurs de
leurs institutions dont l'oratoire saint
joseph
les tribunaux ont refusé ce deuxième
recours y mettre arsenault a fait appel
de cette décision
cette bataille s'annonce longue et
compliquée pourtant lors du premier
recours
cette même congrégation avait indemniser
des victimes et présenter des excuses
aujourd'hui nous demandons pardon à tous
ceux et celles à qui ces événements et
leur suite
on peut causer du tort ils ont à faire
tout de suite un règlement dit mignon
alors c'est quoi le problème
je souhaite vous avez un peu un peu
rapide mc satcom mp2 un s'appeler un an
de négociations un whist un bon teint
ils ont indemnisé bon et je ne et je le
reconnaît d'emblée et je les ai toujours
reconnues non ça s'est gâté un peu après
par des procédures en a plus fait pour
la liquidation c'était la partage d
argent c'était long
c'était du ctb nîmes
comme dans tout recours collectif de
cette nature les victimes doivent
raconter leur histoire par écrit qui
quand où combien de fois le montant
varie selon la gravité du cas par
exemple une pénétration anale est plus
cher qu une masturbation une
masturbation plus que touché par dessus
le pantalon mais encore fallait-il
s'entendre sur les cairns
ils ont contesté la définition de la
masturbation il ya eu des experts qui
ont été engagés pour des la masturbation
ce n'est pas ce que vous pensez c'est
autre chose s'était acheté du revers de
la main
grise on n'a pas assez pour combien de
temps sur cette station d'autres
l'église catholique a longtemps géré les
écarts de ses membres dans le plus grand
secret mais quand ils sont étalées au
grand jour
elle se bat comme le diable dans l'eau
bénite pour protéger les abuseurs et sa
réputation
[Musique]
ils ont d'immenses richesses de
nombreuses propriétés et investissement
mais ils on cache une grande partie pour
les mettre à l'abri des réclamations des
victimes
personne ne s'est attaqué au temps à
l'église catholique que l'avocat
américain jeff and the sun
plus de 1500 poursuite dans plusieurs
états il y a trente ans lorsqu'une
première victime a cogné à sa porte
il a compris qu'il n'y avait pas
seulement le watergate mais aussi un
ticket ils sont loyaux les uns envers
les autres
il tente de réprimer leur sexualité
quand ils n'y arrivent pas ils dansent
la secret ils veulent éviter le scandale
à tout
[Musique]
éviter le scandale un modus operendi qui
a prévalu aux états unis comme partout
l'église canadienne l'aide mais
aujourd'hui c'est certain que pendant
longtemps l'église a voulu protéger sa
réputation c'est le cas dès 1950 1960
1966 1980 je crois qu'on ne se rendait
pas compte de l'impact de l'abus sexuel
sur la vie d'une personne d'une part et
deuxièmement du problème sérieux de la
personne de l'abuseur
l'église a longtemps considéré la
pédophilie comme une faute morale dont
on peut se corriger en traiter les
questions qu'ils pensent de façon
sérieuse mais incomplète
on envoyait de près de faire une
retraite qu'il fasse la résolution de ne
plus recommencer
puis ensuite on faisait confiance on
leur met en position de responsabilité
malheureusement
quand un enfant se plaignait il fallait
étouffer la faire acheter son silence
en 1993 un ancien élève du collège notre
dame à montréal a reçu 250 mais dollars
en indemnisations après avoir dénoncé
deux religieux qui l'ont agressé
sexuellement pendant trois ans le
paiement de 250 mais dollars provenaient
des fonds du collège et non pas de la
congrégation
ce qui veut dire en partie des fonds
publics puisque le collège est
subventionnée et en partie des parents
qui paient les frais de scolarité nous
avons découvert que des institutions
catholiques comptent aussi sur des
compagnies d'assurance pour payer les
crimes de certains de leurs membres
plus de 200 anciens élèves poursuivent
les clercs de saint viateur qui dirige l
institut des sourds de montréal selon
des documents déposés en cour
les clercs de saint viateur s'attendent
à ce que leur compagnie d'assurances
paie la note c sont condamnés mais est
ce possible de s'assurer pour une
agression sexuelle
[Musique]
aucune police d'assurance ne protège un
acte criminel
mais quand un évêque envoie un agresseur
suivre un traitement thérapeutique et
qu'après il le remet en poste dans une
école ou une paroisse et que cet
agresseur récidive alors on considère
que l'évêque a fait preuve de négligence
et la négligence
elle est couverte par une police
d'assurance générale ce qui est plus
problématique selon monseigneur du
rocher c'est le contrôle qu'exercent les
compagnies d'assurance souvent ce sont
les compagnies d'assurance qui mène le
bateau qui embauchent
l'avocat qui dirige il fallut mois que
je me batte avec les compagnies
d'assurances par exemple pour m'assurer
qu'une personne qui arrivait qui était
en douleur qui se plaignait campus lui
offrir au moins des soins thérapeutiques
à ce moment ci le diocèse était prêt à
le faire
l'avocat de l'assurance n'ont fait pas
ça fait pas ça parce que ça c'est une
façon de dire que vous êtes coupable
puis on ne sait pas encore s'ils
voulaient
un archidiocèse va même jusqu'à cacher
son argent pour ne pas payer les
victimes se passe aujourd'hui à meslois
qui au oui ce concert l'archidiocèse
fait face à 580 plein d'agression
sexuelle en 2011 et déclare faillite et
soutient qu'il n'a pas d'argent pour
indemniser les victimes
une correspondance avec le vatican nous
apprend que l'archidiocèse a transféré
50 6 millions de dollars dans un fonds
pour l'entretien du cimetière en
transférant ces fonds dans la fiducie
des jeux prévoit qu'ils seront mieux
protégés contre toute poursuite coup
responsabilité juridique
le vatican a approuvé cette transaction
une cour d'appel fédérale américaine a
ordonné à l'archidiocèse de remettre les
millions dans ses coffres
après des années de bataille
l'archidiocèse accepte de verser 21
millions aux victimes après avoir payé
18 millions de frais d'avocat
au québec dans le cadre du recours
collectif contre les rides dr istres
l'éviter mon cru que la congrégation
avait manoeuvré pour mettre son argent à
l'abri
advenant une condamnation parce qu'en
2010 l'année où le recours collectif est
acceptée la congrégation transfert plus
de 15 millions de dollars vers des
corporations qu'elle dirige au québec et
ailleurs dans le monde
les rédemptoristes ont expliqué que ces
transferts n'avait rien à voir avec le
recours le tribunal les a crus la
congrégation a accepté de rapatrier
l'argent
elle a finalement été condamné à payer
20 millions de dollars aux victimes
la demande c'est à d'avoir
l'autorisation du curateur public afin
d'autoriser le comité des orphelins
organisé des funérailles pour monsieur
onésime logo depuis plusieurs mois ici à
landry se bat avec la curatelle public
pour offrir des funérailles décentes à
son ami onésime au latin dans une fosse
commune et sao n'est pas d'accord la
verso lucien landry n'en est pas à sa
première bataille rapport articles de
journaux lettres photos s'empilent dans
son petit local communautaire des
milliers de documents raconte le combat
mené depuis 30 ans par les orphelins de
duplessis pour obtenir justice
il ya soir et un j'en ai le coeur gros
mais ce qu est la fo compte beaucoup
ils ont vécu seules dans leur lit et ont
laissé les séparent humain c'est pas
vrai qu'ils vont mourir d'un gène était
comme ça ce qu'ont vécu dans leur
enfance bien contents de nous on veut
l'enterrer dignement
est ce que vous direz que ça a donné un
sens à votre vie oui énormément de voir
et d'avoir et de permettre à d'autres
d'avoir accès à leur dignité oui ça
c'est ma plus belle pays ma plus belle
récompense de voir les résultats de
cette démarche locale nous actualisons
même cdh ronald vous dit mais après leur
mort
lucien landry à 74 ans il est né du
péché et le curé hors des liens du
mariage confie aux religieuses alors
qu'il n'avait que 17 jours il deviendra
bien malgré lui un orphelin de duplessis
des milliers d'enfants comme l'y ont été
déclarées fou et traités comme des fous
pour une question d'argent
au début des années 50 les orphelinat
dirigé par les communautés religieuses
éprouvait des difficultés financières
depuis que le fédéral avait coupé le
robinet pour ottawa
ces orphelinats et est de juridiction
provinciale puisqu'on y faisait l'école
pour pallier le problème financier
le premier ministre du québec maurice
duplessis a eu une idée qui va changer
le cours de la vie de milliers d'enfants
[Musique]
il propose au cardinal paul emile léger
de transformer des orphelinats en à z
le calcul est simple les communautés
religieuses recevait 77 pour un orphelin
elles recevront 2 $ sympa pour un fou la
loi est adoptée en une nuit
le 12 août 1954 des orphelins sont
devenus des malades mentaux
avec la collaboration des médecins qui
signe de faux diagnostics
[Musique]
on avait plus d'école on n'avait plus le
droit de sortir et les règlements les
structures les activités taux changes et
à l'intérieur de l'institution et au
nous plaçait comme des malades dans des
salles où on avait plus aucun droit
d'avoir accès l'enseignement scolaire
les religieuses ont fermé les livres
d'école et ont mis ses enfants au
travail
ce qu'ils se rebellaient avait droit à
la camisole de force aux tranquillisants
et aux électrochocs
d'autres ont été plus malchanceux ans
est agressée physiquement ou
sexuellement les deux et soit
physiquement ou des fois c'est d'autres
orphelins que c'était plus sur le plan
de match ou bien d'un cas particulier
était le plus beau on l'appelait je ne
veux pas non maintenant mais c'était le
chouchou du moniteur pour le savez ça
donc avaient des relations sexuelles
avec lui
lucien landry n'a pas été abusée
sexuellement mais il est resté enfermé
réduit à laver la vaisselle et à tourner
en rond
aujourd'hui les orphelins meurt au nahd
dans l'indifférence la plus totale
jean-guy labrosse est décédé en mai
dernier
toute sa vie il a crié à l'injustice
pour ce qu'il a appelé sa chienne de vie
il a été un des premiers à raconter
l'enfer des orphelinats un des
fondateurs du comité des orphelins
il a initié la bataille
le jour de ses funérailles ils ne seront
que huit à se souvenir chose de dire
jeudi à chaque célébration de mettre de
côté peut-être les blessures
occasionnées par des prêtres ou par
l'église jusqu'à leur dernier souffle
on leur dira d'oublier en 1999 le
gouvernement de lucien bouchard présente
des excuses sans pour autant vouloir
jeter le blâme ou imputer une
responsabilité légale à quiconque
le gouvernement reconnaît que la société
québécoise dans son ensemble a un devoir
moral à l'endroit de ses membres qui ont
vécu cette situation malheureuse en plus
d excuse le gouvernement offre à chaque
orphelin 3 mai dollars en services de
soutien
[Musique]
les orphelins refuse
et s'apprête à déposer un recours
collectif lorsque le nouveau premier
ministre bernard landry leur fait une
meilleure offre 25 mai dollars en
moyenne par orphelins
c'est jean claude beauchemin qui a le
mandat de négocier avec les orphelins
il est issu de monsieur la rue se
trouvant une solution qui vous reste à
la fois aller vers justice poursuit
quand éviter qu'ils ne bloquent propos
des communautés religieuses par ailleurs
globalement exact
le gouvernement a rapidement renoncé à
faire payer des communautés religieuses
est-ce que vous pensez que les
communautés devraient je vais je me
souviens pas à quel moment cette piste a
été abandonnée là au début elle était là
au début oui perdre encore de nous
réserver quelques shopi
l'apport du côté des juges je me sens
aucune qu'un refus de ce côté d'angers
prochain avant elle était prête à payer
j'ai passé un type de refus mais d'un
jet a pas de pays
ce règlement est la table des
négociations
un homme aurait parlé plus fort que les
autres l'archevêque de montréal
monseigneur jean claude turcotte il a
dit non non seulement l'église ne paiera
pas elle ne s'excusera pas non plus
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu pour les enfants
subissent une situation bien sûr qu'ils
paient pour eux on la corrige repas en
commettant une injustice à l'endroit des
gens qui ont été les seuls à l'école à
les pendre en cause des excuses à
l'époque était vue comme une
reconnaissance que nous avons fait en
prenant soin de ces enfants n'a été mal
alors que ce que les communautés
religieuses ou les faire c'était du bien
moi ce que j'ai compris ce qu'on m'a dit
c'était que les communautés religieuses
cherchait comment nourrir vêtir
entretenir ces enfants là ils ont vu ça
comme une porte pour l'avoir un peu plus
d'argent pour prendre soin des enfants
en proposant richir mais les religieuses
des religieux vivaient dans la pauvreté
mais aussi les personnes qui mangent du
stic pendant que les enfants mangent et
de l'espagne
mais celui qui a pris la décision de
faire ce déplorable de d'accepter qu'on
avait déclaré ces enfants-là fou oui
c'est le cardinal léger je peux au
volant de sa page pas au courant de ça
alors je peux pour les pages c'est
important que nous puissions
collectivement tourner cette page
d'histoire en 2006 l'état accepte de
dédommager 4000 autres orphelins qui
avaient été exclus du premier programme
encore une fois le gouvernement est seul
à payer la note
au total il aura versé 84 millions de
dollars en indemnisations aux orphelins
de duplessis
le public y alla d'un d'avoir à régler
ce dossier puisque breslau s'étaient ils
peuvent arrêter de crier parce qu'être
analyse orphelins de duplessis
face à des manoeuvres pineuilh par une
lettre en date a tiqué en propageant
excusé pour avoir la paix n'y ont pas
payé cher les orphelins ont longtemps
voulu poursuivre devant les tribunaux ce
qu'il jugeait responsable le
gouvernement
les médecins et l'église mais ils n'ont
pas pu le faire en exceptant une
indemnisation et devait signer une
quittance
en signant cette pitance les orphelins
s'engageait à ne jamais poursuivre
ni le gouvernement ni les médecins ni
les autorités religieuses
notez le job tout cas ce que davies est
menacé c'est sûr vont poursuivre par
quelqu'un qui a signé sur ce que nous
pensions équitables
merci beaucoup bonjour amis seulement
celui qui obtient la cnam payent
d'autres choses mais c'est le
gouvernement du québec les payer c'est
pas comme nous terrer jaws x games and
see gouvernement du québec qui a payé
pour au profit des communautés de vue
c'est logique elles vivent dans un pays
pour donner aux communautés religieuses
une quittance sur le luxe ça tient pas
la route
lucien landry s'est toujours demandé si
cette clause est légal ça a été son
cheval de bataille pendant des années
faire annuler la quittance
je
les étudiants des facultés de droit des
universités de montréal et mcgill ont
finalement accepté d'étudier la faire
gratuitement pro bono sous la
supervision de m pierre fournier ce soir
après des années d'attenté les orphelins
auront enfin des réponses quatre actes
ans est donné il y avait deux parties
qui s'empare des as pas mal seul
problème c'est que les règles ne
s'appliquent pas nécessaire par d'autres
les orphelins ne seront pas plus vous
donnez des grappes et des grains
rousseau s'opposent
[Musique]
les étudiants ne répondront pas à leurs
questions sur la quittance sur les
témoins vous parlez de ce qui arrive au
corps après le décès d'une personne qui
décède son testament dans qu'est ce que
doit contenir un testament premièrement
économie un liquidateur effet de rédiger
un mandat de la petite ça fait peur qui
on tombe tout de suite et il peut y
avoir une réclamation du corps 7 par
quelqu'un d'autre
mais avant de mourir les orphelins
voudrait connaître la vérité ils
réclament depuis plus de 20 ans une
enquête publique
qu'est ce que ça donnerait l'on sait ça
demanderait de vol public qu'elle des
choses sont encore cachés quand ono pour
randy justice aux orphelins il faut dire
mougeotte là que c'est pas une question
d'avoir l'argent sont en jeu aujourd'hui
c'est je pense que si on la compensation
ce qu'on arrête tu fasses d'offrir des
services aux orphelins je vous donne un
exemple pouvait pas imaginer tous les
problèmes qu'on rencontre pour avoir
leur certificat de naissance
la carte d'assurance maladie leur fonds
de pension
la régie des rentes tout seul comme des
citoyen'' normal c'est sûr qu'on sait
tous
cette école et bla d'accès à la justice
c'est pas une question d'argent
[Musique]
chili est journaliste à la rta la
télévision publique d'irlande
en 1998 elle a enquêté avec la
réalisatrice maïwenn fcri ensemble elles
ont parcouru le pays est la rencontre de
plus d'une centaine d'anciens élèves les
écoles industriels les témoignages
kouassi des les 144 personnes que nous
avons rencontrées avaient tout vécu la
même chose mais à différents endroits
l'effet cumulatif était telle qu'il
devenait impossible de nier touch tout
en la personne du land
l'enquète a pris plus d'un an
résultat trois heures de documentaires
diffusés sur trois semaines au printemps
[Musique]
les témoignages ont révélé que des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants ont été
négligés battue et violée dans des
écoles dirigées par des communautés
religieuses dans les années 50 et 60
whiteout comment ce système at il pu
s'étendre au point où des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliers d'enfants ont
été maltraités enfermé au vu et au su de
la société la force de ce documentaire a
été de rassembler pour la première fois
tous les éléments de cette enquête va
tout chambouler ébranlé l'église
catholique comme jamais
18 congrégations sont visés 200 écoles
supervisé par le gouvernement quelques
heures avant la diffusion de la
troisième heure le premier ministre
s'adresse aux victimes nous voulions que
les victimes collabore avec le
gouvernement nous voulions mettre un
terme à leurs souffrances
les excuses était un premier pas après
les excuses
bertie ahern décès d'aller au fond des
choses et met sur pied une commission
d'enquêté indépendante
la commission va yens
des milliers de victimes viendront
raconter tour à tour leur histoire
[Musique]
journaliste des affaires religieuses
pour le irish times a suivi les travaux
de la commission voyenne qui ont duré
neuf ans la commission rails en a
produit un rapport accablant et
scandaleux sur ce qui s'est passé dans
ces institutions durant toutes ces
années
quelles ont été les principales
révélations sur les abus sexuels étaient
endémiques dans les écoles pour garçons
la cruauté la négligence était répandu
dans les écoles pour garçons et les
écoles pour filles ou ont manqué de
nourriture et de vêtements
oui bénite l'éducation était de loin
adéquat
c'était choquant de voir le rôle qui
avait joué l'église mais aussi le
gouvernement qui avait un rôle de
supervision et qui avait permis de
quézac
quinze mille victimes ont reçu en
moyenne 100 mille dollars en
indemnisations
au total une facture de 2 milliards de
dollars
oui nous avons versé un gros montant
mais les sommes payées de la décision de
la commission denquête ksv cela marche
quand il est évident que nous ne
pourrons jamais compenser véritablement
on ne peut pas réparer les vies brisées
on ne peut pas leur donner l'enfant ce
qu'ils auraient dû avoir
certains disent que ce n'est pas aussi
je crois que dans l'ensemble le
règlement a été perçu comme étant juste
une affaire
[Musique]
si la une est restée en contact avec tom
sweeney une des victimes indemnisées par
le gouvernement à 7 ans il a été retiré
de sa famille est placé à orthez une
école industriel dirigé par les frères
des écoles chrétiennes
quand je suis arrivé à l'école
industrielle art est né en 1958 il y
avait 450 garçon je suis resté six ans
les entrées dans cette école c'était
comme entrer dans un autre monde un
monde qu'ils voulaient fuir à tout prix
après huit évasion tom est envoyé à
lattes frac une école de réforme à 200
kilomètres de sa famille isolée
personne n'a répondu à ces cris sacré
boulot chose de cramer agressions
sexuelles commises par les frères des
écoles chrétiennes sur les garçons
étaient courantes
un effort qui est j'ai été abusé par
ceux qui devaient s'occuper de moi c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'oublie pas la
marque à tout jamais
[Musique]
tom sweeney tenait à nous amener dans
ces ruines c'est l'école de réformes
qu'a fréquenté son père il n'a jamais
voulu dire ce qu'il a vécu ici at il été
un bon père tom n'en parlera pas mais il
avoue que lui il a été un homme violent
il a battu sa femme et ses cinq enfants
au sein des docteurs devant moi mais
cinq garçons tous suivi la mauvaise voie
parce que je n'ai pas été un bon père
père aimant qui auraient dû les emmener
en vacances elle s'occupait d'eux ils
n'ont pas connu cela ils ont tous fait
de la prison en reliant lanzhou contre 5
enfants en prison
les frasques des religieux ont eu des
répercussions sur deux générations
le gouvernement a offert à temps sweeney
l'équivalent de 157 mille dollars
canadiens mais à une condition la même
que pour toutes les victimes
son silence a lui fait grève j'ai refusé
parce que je tenais à raconter mon
histoire
refusant de se taire tom sweeney a fait
une grève de la faim devant le parlement
pendant 22 jours le gouvernement a fini
par plier
et c'est un des rares aujourd'hui à
pouvoir parler de cette histoire
les irlandais ont accepté d'indemniser
les victimes
même si la facture s'élevait à 2
milliards
il n'y a pas eu de discussion sur le
coup mais les irlandais tiennent à ce
que les institutions religieuses paie la
moitié de la facture comme le recommande
la commission raion les congrégations
n'ont pas tout payer
il manque 300 millions d'euros
quatre autres commission denquête ont
suivi et provoqué un véritable séisme
dans ce pays aux racines catholiques
profonde des évêques et archevêques de
quatre diocèses ont camouflé des
scandales sexuels et protéger des
agresseurs d'enfants
des monuments athènes a admis que tout
cela est vrai avec son franc parler
l'archevêque de dublin a osé critiquer
publiquement sa propre église et à
l'horizon
[Musique]
à mâcher les 65000 documents qu'il a
remis à la commission denquête ont
permis d'apprendre que l'église
catholique d'irlande avec spa trier des
prêtres pédophiles
c'est l'aveu semble savons maintenant
que des congrégations missionnaires ont
transféré des agresseurs vers la free to
africa
il ya des cas devant les tribunaux ils
en ont aussi expatriés au canada parce
que l'irlande n'a pas de traité
d'extradition avec le canadien il n'a
pas pu être rapatriés avant sa mort
[Musique]
les commissions d enquête ont permis
d'apprendre que l'église catholique
d'irlande voulait dénoncer les
agresseurs à la police mais le vatican
est intervenu pour la rappeler à l'ordre
permettez nous d'exprimer de grandes
réserves quant au signalement
obligatoire
du point de vue moral économique
le premier ministre irlandais est
furieux l'église n'est pas au dessus des
lois de son pays le plus exposé
le premier ministre irlandais rond les
liens diplomatiques entre l'irlande et
le saint siège
après 5 commission denquête l'église
irlandaise a compris qu'elle avait un
problème et elle a mis sur pied un
organisme indépendant pour la surveiller
oui les dossiers sont centralisées pour
la première fois en irlande depuis nos
débuts en 2009 nous avons environ 200
nouvelles allégations
chaque année 200 allégations d'abus
sexuels chaque année
les événements les plus récents
remontent à 2011 je ris adeline un
pouvoir d' enquête dans tous les
diocèses et toutes les communautés
religieuses
elle s'assure que chaque dossier sérieux
et dénoncer à la police
ils sont surveillés je crois que
l'église catholique d'irlande et plus
sûr aujourd'hui pour les enfants le
temps nous le dira dans 20 ans nous
devrions voir le nombre d'allégations
d'abus sur des enfants au sein de
l'église diminué du moins je l'espère
[Musique]
aujourd'hui lucien landry en terre enfin
son ami onésime un autre orphelins de
duplessis
[Musique]
six mois de bataille avec la curatelle
public afin de faire respecter ses
dernières volontés être enterré avec sa
vraie famille seniors fait de moi un
instrument de votre pays
new line que je met l'amour là où il ya
de la france que je mette le pardon là
où il y à la discorde que je mette
l'union là où il ya les erreurs que je
mette la vérité le comité des orphelins
se bat sur plusieurs fronts
en mars dernier lucien landry se rend
devant la commission d'accès à
l'information
il est accompagné de deux bénévoles ils
veulent comprendre le scandale derrière
leur histoire ils demandent à plusieurs
ministères de lui remettre tous les
documents les concernant
sauver la section si lucio landry avait
fait la demande d'accès à l'information
en son nom ça n'aurait pas posé de
problème mais c'est le comité des
orphelins qui l'a fait et selon la loi
tout organisme doit être représenté par
un avocat pour vous demander la
permission à notre retraités oui on n'a
pas d'avocat aujourd'hui parce que
vraiment la commission va débuter là
dessus selon lui il est allé sur les dix
morts de ces orphelins
il aura un problème est que ce combat
parce que vraiment vous allez lambé j'ai
travaillé l'empêché de le replanter les
autres la part de l'avocat pascal moyens
lucien landry est prêt à se représenter
seul malgré la complexité des lois
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on essaie d'avancer
dans ces dossiers d'offre
sargis la procédure et met en état en
respectant la loi
alors nous allons aujourd'hui que je
vais être arraché trois mois plus tard
la décision tombe le comité des
orphelins n'a pas accès à la commission
d'accès
pas d'avocat pas d'audience lucia landry
vient de perdre ses dernières illusions
à rechercher cette à l'émission enquête
se bat depuis six ans pour avoir accès
des documents concernant les orphelins
de duplessis
même si la commission lui a donné en
partie raison
le gouvernement subjugue et multiplient
les appels
il invoque la confidentialité des
mémoires ministérielle ce qui confirme
une chose pour le comité des orphelins
seule une commission denquête pourrait
vraiment faire la lumière sur leur
histoire et de façon plus large sur tous
les abus sexuels commis par des
religieux locaux par le coach manceau
pas petits morceaux comme outil d'une
jeunesse désespéré ce sera pour mon
manteau j'espère qu'on va oublier tout
ça celle au bénin pour limiter
au québec six cents personnes se sont
manifestés jusqu'ici dans le cadre de
recours collectif contre des religieux
une commission d' enquête permettrait de
savoir si les religieux ont fait plus de
victimes permettrait de connaître
l'ampleur du scandale
aujourd'hui à personne c'est une
commission d enquête avec une
intervention gouvernementale pourrait
avancer les choses
en espagne peut-être cette commission
d'enquêté pour faire en sorte que les
délits tam autorités des congrégations
religieuses qui ont souvent dans des
diocèses du québec d un losc avec le
staff est longue on arrête selon bâle et
téléphonie lopy on voit une des mises et
les gens collector je n'oserais jamais
dire au québec coiffeur expérience mais
je crois que c'était la chose à faire
est rude et d'ouest en est et ce que
vous accepteriez de collaborer à une
grande enquête pour aller au fond des
choses qui responsable qui a su qu'il
faut faire les choses comme il fallait
comment on a géré ces troubles ce qu'il
serait prêt à vous asseoir et mon
expérience à quoi noir d'unix d'une
enquête qui dure et 80 et qui écoute et
50 millions de dollars
je dirais que il doit y avoir d'autres
façons de faire ça pour arriver aux
mêmes fins pour permettre aux victimes
de raconter leur histoire pour permettre
qu'il y ait des rencontres 2
de guérison il me semble que la
commission denquête à cause de toute la
structure juridique de la présence de
multiples avocats de la lourdeur de la
procédure ni pas de chemin pour ce genre
de processus là
monseigneur du rocher considère que ça
ne sert à rien de regarder en arrière
les diocèses ont changé leur politique
il évite les victimes à dénoncer leur
agresseur à la police vous avez dû
rencontrer a connu un mois ya des gens
qui avaient abusé d'enfants que vous
saviez
qu'est ce que vous leur avez dit qu'est
ce que vous l'avez qu'est ce qu'on dit à
une abuseurs d'enfants
je ne sais pas quoi dire je ne sais pas
quoi dire
il y en a qui ont demandé pardon et
c'est un pas dans la bonne direction
il y en a d'autres qui sont tellement
malade qui ne se rend pas encore
aujourd'hui son cocon du dommage qu'ils
ont fait six des agresseurs ne se
rendent pas compte du mal qu'ils ont
fait l'église toujours plus préoccupé à
protéger son image et son argent ne se
rend pas compte qu'il faut plus que des
prières pour réparer des vies brisées
[Musique]